[Music]
I know what you're
thinking who is this guy with the
incredible cheekbones where does he get
his hair done one day I'll be the most
famous highway men in all of England you
are literally about to be hang you idiot
quick note to my gang if you were
planning a rescue now would be a good
time you've probably heard of me dick
tping new leader of the Essex gang High
women murder and Rob you're not a
Highwayman dick I've got this we strike
on three one
two we'll get the next one I've seen you
prancing around on your funny shirt I'm
new score and there's going to be less
violence on my watch is there anything
that I could have done to improve your
highway robbery experience but we're
just as tough as any other gang in here
here's your peppermint te dick put a
splash of honey in it I know you got a
scratchy throat thanks little C there's
only one man brainless enough to steal
from The
Syndicate thank you dick I don't know
what we do without
[Music]
you going to be
famous Dick Turpin Dick Turpin Dick
Turpin Dick Turpin Dick Turpin I want
this dick in my hands as soon as
possible that sounds weird yeah that did
sound a bit weird all
[Music]
right